[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about probably the craziest
chapter of attack on Titan ever chapter
112 stuff is really picking up now and
it's absolutely insane a bunch of you
have been asking for an attack on Titan
Chapter Review so this video
specifically goes out to you guys if you
want to see more videos like this one on
the channel make sure to go beast mode
on that like button to let me know if
you haven't subscribed and ring that
magic YouTube Bell so future attacks on
Titan videos get sent straight to your
phone lastly if you love attack on Titan
and want to support content like this at
the same time definitely check out our
attack on Titan beast mode shirt at
anime out Broadcom fans of the channel
can get 25% off by using the code uproar
25 at check out anyways obviously
spoiler alert if you're not caught up
and let's jump right into chapter 112 so
we start to chapter with the idea that Z
has placed his spinal fluid into all
that wine if that's the case
high-ranking officers and others drank
it meaning he can turn them into Titans
with a scream we got a quick flash back
showing Zeke's genius hanji points out
that Zeke told them that LD ins freeze
the moment they drink his spinal fluid
so that no one would ever think they've
been poisoned by it if that sign ever
came as she puts it The effect of that
believable lie is immense
keep in mind according to attack on
Titan data book on Z and Z core two of
the smartest characters in the series
and I look forward to seeing more back
and forth between them but I'd say Zeke
definitely has the upper hand as of now
then we got a hilarious scene that ISA
Emma gave us Armin Mikasa and Gabi are
talking and on the next page we see a
figure enter the room in the background
and it's Aaron you say I'm at the
creator of attack on Titan is so funny
to me because of scenes like this
usually you'd expect a moment like this
Aaron's sudden reappearance to take up a
full page and be portrayed like a big
deal but he salmon just hasn't show up
in the background unenthusiastically and
just stroll on in brilliant then we cut
to flawed who has multiple armed men
with him and they pull guns out the
survey Corps which has been losing
ground in power for a while
ready we then get back to Aaron who is
sitting at the table with me Casa Arman
and Gabi let me know how you guys feel
about this but for me Titan action is
awesome but what's impressive about ISA
Yama is how he can make for character
sitting around a table and talking more
interesting than any battle maybe it's
just me but this conversation had me on
the edge of my seat and we got so much
valuable information while so much
emotion was being conveyed I absolutely
think it was situated brilliantly right
away before the talking even starts
there's all this pent-up tension Gabi
the girl who killed Sasha is there with
Aaron the worst of the island dwellers
that she has been brainwashed to hate
and the man directly responsible for the
death of her friends throw in Arman who
has been itching to talk to Aaron and
then Myka saw who we know has always
defended Aaron and took his side but
even she has begun to wonder what's
going on since he seemingly betrayed
them all even though all three of them
used to be such close friends it seems
like we finally got to get answers since
most importantly we have Aaron right
there who seemingly has all the answers
to everything
Arman and Micah's are wondering about
along with us we can finally hear Aaron
side of the story so even before the
conversation really starts we have a
perfect setup
Aaron gives some very interesting
information he says he is free and not
being controlled by Zeke he makes it
clear that he is choosing whatever he
does with his own free will
then we have one of the most
heartbreaking scenes in attack on Titan
so far which is saying a lot in a series
where we saw the main characters mom get
gruesomely eaten before his eyes in the
first episode but I stand by it
because it refuses to accept what Aaron
is saying and says he's being controlled
Aaron does not seem amused and his blank
look is starting to remind me of the
look in the eyes of the other founding
Titan users which kind of makes sense
because even if he's not of royal blood
now he has the founding Titan along with
the memories of so many other Titan
users in his mind
anyways Mikasa tells him that he's not
the kind of person who would involve
innocent civilians and children even if
they were on the enemy's side she also
tells us that he's cared and thought
about her and Armin more than anyone
pleading with him she says haven't you
and reminds him that he saved her from
kidnapped and wrapped a scarf around her
that she's been wearing since that day
she thinks he did this all out of his
own kindness and you can see the emotion
in her face and how badly she's hanging
on his next words Aaron though
completely denies her narrative she's
trying to talk to him like they're close
friends or even family but he simply
says with an emotionless face for Mika
so to keep her hands on the table in
this way he makes it clear that they're
not talking as friends but talking as
possibly hostile enemies and then oh my
God look at Micah's his poor face she
listens and puts her hands back down I
may be more affected than most by
Micah's his pain and reaction here
because I think she's best girl but dear
God
I definitely feel for her here then
Aaron admits that he spoke with Zeke
brother-to-brother this is significant
that he's using the word brother because
he is situating Zeke as family while as
we just saw he no longer views Mika so
that way then we get some crazy
information that Aaron heard from Zeke
Aaron knows that Armand is seeing Annie
and Aaron asks if he's going because of
his will or bed volts Arman is nervous
and shook suggesting that Aaron is on to
something I say this before that
memories of past iron users live on in
the current ein user and can even shape
their actions so in a sense the old
Titan user is not dead but lives on in
the current one and Aaron suggests that
that theory was correct
he says if memories play a major role in
forming who a person is that means part
of you has become been told now we're
entering ghost in the shell' territory
are we more than the sum of our memories
for instance if you passed on all your
memories to a cyborg body and your
physical body died and the cyborg with
all your memories could think and act
for itself and pick up new memories have
you survived in that cyborg can that be
considered you let me know what you
think I'm fascinated with stuff like
this so I look forward to hearing your
thoughts anyways as I previously thought
Aaron is suggesting that bedposts own
love of Annie is amplifying Arman's own
emotions for her Aaron says the Benton's
memories completely changed Armin and
rather than being a man of action
now Armin only wants to talk and how
become in Aaron's words useless so Aaron
tells Arman that he's being controlled
by Bethel or in other words the enemy
this is interesting because a little
while ago he said all of his decisions
are of his own free will and yet he says
that Arman who has way less memories
inside of himself than Aaron is not
making decisions of his own free will
clearly there's a problem with this and
if Aaron is right about Arman he has to
be more influenced by the memories of
previous Titan holders of the attack
Titan founding Titan and more hammer
tightened then he is letting on then
Aaron explains his philosophy he thinks
that there is nothing further removed
from freedom than ignorance so in other
words Aaron seeks freedom and he equates
that with knowing the truth then he
drops the big bombshell about the
Ackerman's we already knew that the
Ackerman's are the result of Titan
biology or the result of experimenting
with the power of the Titans
but Aaron gives us more specifics as
Aaron points out the Ackerman's maintain
a human form but in some cases can
manifest the power of titans
which explains why Mikasa and Levi are
so strong he goes on to say that the
Ackerman clan was designed to protect
LDS King as a result the instincts in
their blood will activate only when they
recognize someone as a host then Aaron
says Mikasa clings to him because of her
instincts as an actor 'men and Mikasa is
shocked
he says she obeyed his order to fight
back when they were kids and it was at
that point that the instincts hidden
inside the Ackerman clans blood were
awakened not only did this heightened
her physical abilities to an extreme she
was even given experience in battle
accumulated by every past Ackerman by
way of a path this is a huge detail that
we were not aware of
so like previous Titan holders pass on
their memories to the new one Ackerman's
pass on battle experience to each other
so in theory every new Ackerman would be
stronger than the ones that came before
and they would keep becoming better and
better fighters because they just keep
accumulating more and more experience so
even though everyone thought that me
Casal of Aaron Aaron says that she
simply tricked herself into believing he
was the hole she had to protect she says
he's wrong
that was because it was
Aaron that she was able to become strong
that it was all because of him and she's
not explicitly saying it but she's
pretty much saying that it was all
because of her love for him and then
Aaron crushes her emotionally he says
once an acraman awakens they start
having headaches and that this happens
out of the true self trying to resist
being forced to protect its host
he asks Myka said this sounds familiar
and mica says face suggests it does she
is mentally collapsing and she gives a
weak no but Aaron is sure of himself and
he keeps going he says the real Myka saw
disappeared all that time ago leaving
only a never faithful ackerman slave
Aaron says he hates anyone who isn't
free
Myka son looks completely destroyed and
Arman is shouting in anger as he's
witnessing how Aaron is making me cosa
feel and man honestly I would totally do
the same if I were witnessing this in
Arman's place then Aaron puts the final
nail in the coffin when he says that
he's always hated me Casas and we see
actual tears in the best girl's eyes
Arman can't stand it anymore took you
long enough bro and jumps at Aaron only
to be stopped by Mikasa Aaron suggests
that this is evidence that she is only
living in accordance to her ackerman
blood and he says that's all she is and
she continues to cry this time Armin
lands a punch but Mikasa interestingly
enough doesn't stop him then Aaron tells
Armin as they fight that they've never
fought before because arming couldn't
even put up a fight against him and
Aaron proceeds to beat his former best
friend up Mekas is still crying saying
stop Aaron does stop and reaffirms that
they'll tell him where Zeek is Armin
says is that the freedom you wanted the
freedom to hurt Mikasa who's the real
slave he asks him angering Eren so
before we were saying at these three
were drifting apart and that definitely
culminated in this chapter where Aaron
said he always hated Mikasa and beat up
Armin let me know what you guys think do
you believe that Eren always hated
Micasa or do you think he's actually
hurt because he thought she loved him
and cared about him and was upset to
find out that it was all fake and only
the result of Ackerman blood and that
frustration explains his current behave
towards her do you think me kisses
feelings were not her own all this time
do you think that Zeke purposely told
Aaron wrong information to manipulate
him and turn him against his friends I
mean these are all possibilities but let
me know what you think keep in mind that
Mikasa is part Japanese too and so is it
believable to think that all of who she
is is just the result of her Ackerman
blood I don't want to think so
personally but she's definitely gonna be
affected by an identity crisis in the
chapters to come as will Armin who now
knows that he could be significantly
affected by bad thoughts memories now if
that wasn't enough insanity for one
chapter we then get Levi and Zeke action
levi decides that he is going to kill
Zeke no matter what then Zeke screams
and all the soldiers that are there to
stop him if he activates his beast
heightened ability or themselves turned
into Titans meaning they had already
consumed his spinal fluid and the fear
about the wine was in fact true and that
Zeke did lie when he said people freeze
up right after consuming his bodily
fluid and that is it for this insane
chapter not a lot of physical action per
se but I'd say it was nonetheless one of
the most intense emotional and
interesting ones we know that Zeke did
lie before and that he is willing to lie
so the question is did he lie to Aaron
or does he also view Aaron first and
foremost as a brother rather than as a
pawn in his plan we'll have to wait and
see but we should definitely see Zeke
enter his beast Titan form in the next
chapter and possibly even fight with
Levi if you watch this far in the video
drop a hashtag beast mode in the
description to let me know and remember
that you can support this channel and
get awesome attack on Titan merch at the
same time at anime up roared comm link
in the description if you enjoyed this
video go be smooth on that like button
and go accurate mode on that subscribe
button and ring that magic youtube bell
to keep up to date and until next time
see you space cowboy
[Music]
you